maybe you can find I care in there I'm
not gonna flirt with girls at the mosque
why not the girls in there are high
quality the mosque is for praying it's
not for picking people up and it's like
a bunch of families too and you can't
just walk up to a Muslim girl and like
start spitting game or something what am
I supposed to say like hey can I get
your father's number yes why not
comedian Rami use of is the star and
co-creator of the popular series Rami on
Hulu it follows a young practicing
Muslim American as he navigates
everything from family pressures to
dating the New York Times called it a
quietly revolutionary comedy well his
first HBO comedy special is called Rami
Yousef feelings in this clip Rami shares
why Friday can be a bit tricky for him
in prayer there's Friday prayers and
then there's Friday night I hope you
have Friday prayers I'm listening to the
Imam and I'm like yo this is me man I go
out Friday and see the most beautiful
one I've ever seen I'm like no this is
me I think this is this is Wow the prey
on Friday it's like getting your car
washed before a hurricane in the studio
Rami good morning morning oh my gosh
what can I say in this clip you you you
talk about your faith so openly it just
pours right out of you why was it
important for you not to shy away from
it at all well I was really excited with
the show and with the special to kind of
bring a little bit of a different
perspective for someone my age my
generation a little yeah I'm still you
know holding on to their faith holding
on to their culture in an honest way I
think a lot of the times we see stories
of first-generation immigrant and
they're trying to push away their family
trying to push away their culture their
position where they come from and I
wanted to make a story that could
show what it's like to try and hold on
to it you know when you have what you
believe and then what you actually do
and there's kind of a space in the
middle and and so that's a lot of what
I've explored and stand up and then we
explored on the show were you trying to
be quietly revolutionary as a New York
Times cult yeah every day really since I
was a kid I was like let's make this
revolution a whisper a hushed tone but
really you know a revolution for sure
but you're you're raunchy here and there
sometimes you don't shy away from that
either oh we got to be real gotta show
it and then my mom will yell at me later
but yeah you know we do what we got to
do so when I think about the show I
think about I once heard Seinfeld and
Larry David talk about they just tried
to make a good show right you know
couple white guys let's just make a
comedy you've got to think about
representation you've got to think about
education how do you fit comedy into all
that I just go again we go to try make a
good show like thinking about it yeah we
really we have to yeah because if you go
in thinking oh man this is the first
show with an Arab Muslim family and you
take on all this weight it's really not
fair even the idea of saying first
there's like a desperation to it because
it's almost like oh it might be the last
you put on all this weight if you go
like that marketing is gonna pushed on
you because it's in everything that's in
anything yeah I mean it's just the truth
I guess of the landscape but you can't
really write to that and you can't take
on that weight because otherwise you
make something that's really tough to
watch if you're trying to check every
box and represent everything we called
it Rami because it's just my story and
you know we just wanted to start from
there and hopefully that opens up other
stories to be told so are you conscious
of it at all while you're doing it
though yeah I mean you have to on a
level but you try to have it not affect
the writing and not affect what you're
doing and whether you know I mean
because you know literally everyone
who's ever said Habibi in America is
calling me and is like dude I can't wait
you know I can't wait for you to do it
and it's exciting and it's really
exciting to feel that support but you're
making the show and you got to make
something unique to yourself I have to
tell you it was so stark to me was all
of the stereotypes that you do hit on
you managed to hit every nerve strike
every every you know trope and and
there's some I didn't even realize we're
there yeah
yeah we we went for it I mean it's
definitely not an easy watch sometimes
but we wanted to make something that
felt real and so it's every family
member that you try to hide this in the
show every conversation you try to run
away from is also in the show speaking
of family members you may try to hide
you grew up in a household where your
father was manager of the Plaza Hotel oh
yeah you have a bit in the in the
standup yeah about how there was a
picture in your house with Donald Trump
and your father Donald Trump was manager
of the plot he was owner father was
manager and and where you come from
anybody who's shaking your father's hand
picture is your uncle yeah and your
uncle run for president yeah he has we
all have that uncle you know we all have
that uncle that just says crazy stuff
and so yeah it kind of felt like that I
guess it was really bizarre I mean
knowing that my father is an immigrant
who is part of the businesses that have
made him rich I think he's rich yeah and
so it's it's odd when you because we you
know my dad had a good relationship with
him so I don't really have anything
negative to say on a personal front and
that's what's weird when you see the
public rhetoric versus what you know to
be true in private is bizarre and so
highlighting that and knowing that from
a personal place was was something that
felt like that worth bringing up how did
your parents journey here influenced
your comedy so much I mean because you
know when people come from a different
place obviously my parents wanted to be
here and continue to want to be here and
so you feel that pull to to your
homeland but you also feel you know
really happy to be here and so for me
growing up here it's just there's this
constant you know back and forth and and
that's really what the the comedy
describes and explains and and I feel
this pull to be here but also that's
pull to go to Egypt where my family's
from and we actually spend the last
month of our shoot in Cairo and we shot
our last two episodes there and it was
really amazing
Kamiya yeah it was crazy it was really I
mean we shot one of our locations was
three blocks from the apartment my dad
grew up in and so it was it was
really yeah it was really get me looks
there people were so excited I think
people were so fun that we're shooting a
show there because a lot of film happens
there but that it was like a u.s. show
everyone was really a problem
all right rot me well thanks for
stopping by the quiet revolution
continues I guess we're gonna keep it
quiet
yeah don't tell anyone thank you very
much it's comedy special drama Yusuf
feelings from here Saturday June 29th on
HBO it's terrific it's also gonna be
controversial people should tune in also
Rami is available now on pool